okay hi everyone so I'm here to do a Q&A
about science and technology for kids
and others and our main topic last
couple of weeks which we're going to
continue this week is kind of questions
about things from science fiction that
might or might not become real and I
noticed we have a few questions left
over from last week and I could perhaps
some start with some of those so first
what I'm seeing here how far away are we
from a new propulsion system that could
take us to another galaxy well I'm
afraid we're a long way away first thing
to know is if you want to get a
spacecraft into orbit around the earth
you need to have it go at 17,000 miles
an hour if you want it to escape from
the gravity of the earth you need to
have it go at 25,000 miles an hour if
you want it to escape from the gravity
of the Sun so that it's able to leave
the whole solar system it has to go at a
hundred thousand miles an hour and if
you wanted to escape the gravity of our
galaxy it has to go at a million miles
an hour so you have to be able to get
your spacecraft to go really fast
um and the question is how on earth
would you do that and the the current
approach to making spacecraft is
basically you've you're you're burning
of fuel and when you burn the fuel it
gets hot and the the gas that is that is
produced is going very quickly
and the gas goes out in one direction
and because when you push something when
you if you if you throw a ball there'll
be a slight reaction
that will push you back and in general
when you push something out with lots of
momentum in one direction you in order
to conserve momentum you get pushed in
the other direction and that's that's
basically the idea of rockets is you've
got to have something in the rocket that
can be pushed out that will will make
the rocket go forwards and the most
common way to do that the way that
most Rockets work is using chemical
reactions and essentially burning they
might burn hydrogen in oxygen so that
that that some it's a reaction which is
is releases a lot of energy and that's
how the rocket is propelled forward now
there are a few other ideas for how to
do things I think I mentioned in some
other of these some of these live
streams like ion propulsion where
instead of instead of having a gas be
pushed out you're you're pushing out
ions or even electrons using electrical
processes from your spacecraft but
that's only used to make very tiny it's
only so far been used to make very very
tiny kind of pushes to the spacecraft
not not the kind of thing that you need
to like make the spacecraft go at a
million miles an hour there are other
schemes that involve having a spacecraft
a very tiny spacecraft using a big solar
sail type thing and using the pressure
that you get from an intense beam of
light to push the spacecraft forward
where they're in that case you might
have a big laser on the earth but it's
trying to push the spacecraft away from
the earth by having the the energy that
you need to run the laser be something
that's on earth but then you get to push
the spacecraft away but that's not gonna
work by the time the spacecraft is on
the other side of the galaxy you're
really out of luck in terms of that okay
so what other possibilities are there
well you need something which is going
to release a lot of energy to make the
spacecraft go forwards and maybe it's
something that you keep on the
spacecraft but then it's gonna be hard
to do that because if you want to keep
the spacecraft accelerating going faster
and faster and faster you're you're
probably going to run out of fuel quite
quickly and most rockets
you know when spacecraft are going to
the moon or something they are burning
their rocket engines only for a matter
of I think at most a few minutes and
intensely pushing themselves to go
faster and faster once once they're
going at a certain speed the newton's
laws of motion for example say something
which is not acted on by any force just
keeps going at the same speed in a
particular direction until it's acted on
by some force so if you are if you're a
spacecraft and you manage to escape the
gravity of the earth and you just
pointed in some direction and you're
going with some speed you just keep
going in that direction until some other
force like a force of gravity from some
other planet or something acts on you so
so that's some okay so what else could
you possibly do so here's another here's
another thing you could do an
alternative to like keeping so one
question is can you keep the fuel on the
spacecraft and have it go faster and
faster and faster that's tough because
you know if you put a lot of fuel on the
spacecraft the spacecraft itself is
going to be very heavy and that means
it's harder to make it go faster so okay
so here's another trick which has been
used by spacecraft in the Solar System
which is a gravitational slingshot trick
so the idea is you're a spacecraft and
you are approaching some planet and you
basically get pulled in by the gravity
of the planet and as you've got pulled
in for example by the gravity of Jupiter
you'll go faster and faster and faster
and faster and faster so for example for
the earth I don't know what it is for
Jupiter I'd have to try and work it out
and you know I'm gonna make a guess it
might be 60,000 miles an hour but I'm
not sure we can we can go umm wolfmann
alpha can certainly tell us the answer
to this what the escape velocity of
Jupiter is but but basically if you are
let's say it's 60,000 miles now you know
what I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
compute this I'm sorry I'm just I want
to actually give you a give you the true
answer Jupiter escape velocity I'm just
typing in 12 now for you could probably
ask um Siri which will go ask or from
alpha okay oh I was wrong the escape
velocity of Jupiter is a hundred and
thirty-four thousand miles an hour okay
so if a spacecraft is approaching
Jupiter and was just gonna go from from
being at rest somewhere it was gonna go
faster and faster and faster and faster
faster and eventually was gonna hit the
surface of Jupiter whatever that means
what we can talk about what that means
cuz Jupiter is a gas planet and so it
doesn't really have a solid surface but
let's say until you get to the point we
hit the upper level of clouds on Jupiter
if you go from from just being at rest
which is falling falling falling towards
Jupiter you you will fall
eventually you will be going at 134,000
miles an hour when you hit the the upper
atmosphere of Jupiter okay so let's
imagine that you got this spacecraft
it's falling towards Jupiter and it's
going faster and faster and faster just
because of the gravity of Jupiter it's
pulling it making it accelerate okay but
now let's say that instead of actually
hitting Jupiter you arrange for the
spacecraft to just go - not to slightly
miss Jupiter to go round the side um
then what you find happens is that you
will be successfully going at 134
thousand miles an hour or almost as you
as you go you know you because you would
be about Jupiter but actually you you
miss it and then what happens is that
you get pulled around in sort of half an
orbit around Jupiter if you arrange it
correctly and you're still going at that
speed and then you go off in some other
direction I'm actually actually can keep
going I have to think about this I think
you can keep going in more or less the
same direction but you've been
accelerated by by the gravity of Jupiter
so now actually what I said isn't quite
right what what what you want to do is
is you approach Jupiter and you just
glanced off the side of it and then keep
going in that same direction that's that
that's the better way to do it and then
so you're using the gravity of Jupiter
to speed you up so it's kind of like I
don't know what the good analogy is but
but um so that's one way to make a
spacecraft go faster is you know find
your friendly planet and almost hit it
but just arrange to not hit it and use
its gravity to make you go faster so
that would be another approach another
thing you can do is say well you know
let's not keep the spacecraft and it's
going to keep the fuel on the spacecraft
let's collect the fuel from just sort of
forage the fuel from from what's out
there in space well the problem is that
isn't a lot in space there's about one
hydrogen atom per cubic meter in space
roughly in interstellar space and
actually when you're going really really
fast that you know having a hydrogen
atom hit you is actually not a great
thing but let's imagine you could have
some big collector that would sort of
vacuum up all of these hydrogen atoms
and you can use that as a piece as fuel
for your spacecraft and that way you
might have some way to avoid having to
keep the fuel for the spacecraft on the
spacecraft
so what other schemes are there well
there are some other much more exotic
schemes actually there's some physics
that I did a long time ago that was used
by science fiction folk to invent a kind
of at least a conceptual idea for how to
make interstellar propulsion system
based on so-called zero-point energy of
the vacuum I don't think the scheme that
they proposed would work but it is
certainly conceivable with this theory
of physics that we have now that
something like that could work although
I don't know how to make it work but so
the idea is this so in the vacuum you
might think there's absolutely nothing
there in the vacuum there's no matter
there's no particles there's no nothing
it's just vacuum empty space turns out
that's not a correct view of what's
happening in physics instead the space
this kind of has to be made out of some
sort of atoms of space they're not like
atoms of matter they're like these
points that get knitted together to make
space to make this thing that has sort
of that that we can move through and
exist in and so on
and that process of kind of creating
space is something we're at a very very
very tiny scale you know trillions and
trillions and trillions of times smaller
than the natum for example um there are
there processes going on that are very
lots of activity there so that activity
actually creates essentially energy that
exists throughout space throughout even
when there's a vacuum there's some
energy that's associated with that
vacuum now we don't notice that there's
energy there because the energy is
everywhere so we only notice when we add
energy to the vacuum and we we do things
which which add we're when it's just
vacuum it's like well that's the same as
it always is we don't notice that it's
there so one possibility would be if
there was a way to sort of arrange to
have some of that activity that exists
in the vacuum not occur in a particular
place in space is somewhat amusingly I
was referring to this recently as a
vacuum cleaner so to speak something
which will take the all the activity
that's in the vacuum of space and
sort of not have it happen in some
regional vacuum we don't know how to
make that happen we don't know how to
achieve that we don't know how to sort
of make a box that will have walls that
are sort of impenetrable enough that
even this process that sort of knits
together the structure of space can't
penetrate the box we don't know how to
do that but if we could do that we would
have this huge energy imbalance because
there'd be all the stuff outside the box
that's all this activity that's making
space but inside the box there'd be less
activity so there'd be sort of a huge
difference in energy between what's
outside and what's inside and that
difference would almost certainly let
one create kind of let one create some
sort of engine that's like a rocket or
something that would do things but we
don't know how to create that kind of
vacuum cleaner like thing so you know
there are other other schemes like this
but I think um well ok so another
possibility okay there's an interesting
one I haven't thought about this before
is you know I mentioned this idea of
this sort of slingshot II thing around
Jupiter what if you have a black hole so
a black hole has the feature the black
hole is like a collapsed star and for
example the center of our galaxy there's
a very big black hole that's like 10,000
collateral you know that sort of 10,000
stars collapsed into it and a black hole
is something where the escape velocity
where there's so much gravity that the
escape velocity is the speed of light
and that means because nothing can go
faster than the speed of light that
means nothing can escape from the black
hole and that's why it's black because
if nothing nothing as as the any light
that comes through is just absorbed by
the black hole it never gets never gets
transmitted back to sort of show up as
as as light so the idea would be given
that the escape velocity of the black
hole is the speed of light you can you
can imagine that the same effect that I
was mentioning with Jupiter you could
you could be pulled in towards the black
hole but you could just avoid the black
hole and you could use that as a way to
kind of accelerate to to approach the to
escape the galaxies actually that's not
a terrible idea it might actually work
so let me tell you what I what I do know
about that
so black holes have have a lot of
gravity they have so much gravity that
they're actually pretty good at ok so
here's an extreme thing that can happen
with a certain kind of black hole a
photon can go into a photon of light can
go into orbit around a black hole so
normally you think light it's just going
in straight lines whatever it's it's
some you know you don't imagine that
there's a possibility that light could
be so pulled by gravity that it actually
can go into orbit around around a black
hole but that can happen and actually
about a month ago some some people I
know actually announced sort of an
observation of of something which seems
like it's it's like photons going into
orbit around a black hole so that's a
that's sort of a type of thing that you
can do but but I think this idea of
using the gravity of a black hole to to
accelerate you to go really fast is
might might might actually work you have
to compute it it's it's some gosh I
could by going super much more technical
I could actually start to think about
how you would compute that I I think um
it reminds me there's a strange
phenomenon called gravitational lensing
so how does a how does a lens what does
the lens do when you when you have light
you look through a lens look through a
magnifying glass something like that
what's what's happening to the light
well what's happening is the rays of
light from something might all be
parallel but then the lens if it's a
lens that's are bulging out lens or
convex lens then what it does is it will
concentrate the light so the rays of
light will be coming in parallel but
then they'll be made to converge and
that the light rays will eventually
converge at a point and that's why for
example if you take a magnifying glass
and like where I am right now today it's
the Sun is out and it's it's kind of you
know this it's you know you can so if
you take if I took a magnifying glass
outside and I took it and I you know
have let's say a black piece of paper or
something which absorbs lots of light
but even what will white piece of paper
they're not as quickly and I I
concentrate the light from the Sun in a
point I can use
magnifying glass which is a convex lens
to concentrate the light from the Sun
and a point on a piece of paper I can
burn that piece of paper don't
necessarily recommend the experiment
that term and if you do that make sure
you you don't don't look at the spot of
light it's really bright and it'll hurt
your eyes but but what's happening there
is that the the the light from the Sun
the sort of rays of light from the Sun
are coming in parallel they they go
through the the lens and then they're
made to converge together and get
focused to the point and that's what a
typical lens does okay so here's a weird
effect imagine you have a star or black
hole and it it is capable of taking you
know a photon of light and as the photon
goes near the black hole or near the
high gravitational high mass object the
the photon will be turned and in fact
photons on the two sides will be will be
focused together and so that that
phenomenon is called gravitational
lensing and it's actually a phenomenon
that's been observed in the universe and
that's a that's an example of something
that happens in um in in actual and and
it kind of it causes one to for example
if you if you kind of trace where the
Rays go it means that there can be if
there's a galaxy and it's behind this
like black hole or something then you
might actually see two images of that
galaxy because the light will go in two
different directions around the black
hole and then will be will be turned so
that it so that it so that both those
images reach us on earth so so I guess
my answer is that okay there's a there's
a possible idea which requires a bit
more bit more work to understand is if
you get your spacecraft all the way to
some your your local neighborhood black
hole we don't actually know where the
nearest black hole is I think what has
the guess well the nearest star along
the Sun is four light-years away um I
would suspect that there aren't any
black holes within a hundred light-years
of where we are but I'm not certain of
that and I'm not sure if it's actually
known um I think that the it's kind of
hard to detect you can use gravitational
lensing
for example the defect detect the
presence of black hole if the black hole
is is stars only form black holes when
they're a bit heavier than the Sun like
one and a half times heavier than the
Sun um so unless black holes come from
some origin other than a collapsing star
they have to be quite large and I guess
we don't know I think by the time we're
a thousand light years away I think
there are no in black holes I'm not sure
you can look up there's one black hole
that's some famous one that's a star
called Cygnus x1 which is um was the
first kind of star that was distance
from Earth oh boy okay much further than
I thought it's 5,600 light-years away
from Earth so that's the that's a star
that actually around the black hole
things are being pulled in so quickly by
the black hole that it's actually
producing x-rays instead of visible
light as a result of processes that
happen near the black hole so anyway
there that's at least one thought for
how we get out of the galaxy but I mean
hopefully there's a in order to make
that work you have to kind of you know
you have to solve the problem of getting
to the nearest star other than the Sun
and that's already a very hard problem
okay
let's see gosh a lot of
trust in question see all right let me
let me look at some of the new ones that
have come in here um oh here's a
question from Brian here what about a
railgun in space that launches rockets
yeah actually there are people who are
trying to do things like that so a
railgun works by using electromagnetism
too so so if you have a magnetic field
well you have a magnet you can use
magnets to pull other things and in a
railgun you're using kind of a certain
kind of magnet to to just accelerate
things so that they go very fast and so
the idea of a railgun is you might make
something go um you know the notion is
that for example you might use it as a
gun as the name railgun suggests and it
might make something like a a big shell
or something go at let's say 2,000 miles
an hour pretty fast you can make rail
guns that make things go faster than
bullets from from guns that are that are
that are powered by sort of chemical
processes same kind of processes that
power rockets
so rail guns are a way of shooting
something out really fast so there's
actually a people have thought about
using rail guns to launch satellites
into orbit um and in fact there's a
company that has been doing tests on
something much more exotic than that
their idea is I think it's called I
forget its name but anyway their idea is
that you literally are twirling
something around really really fast and
you know when you you have something on
a string for example and you've got to
wait at the end of a string and you
twirl it around the the the weight is
pulling away from you it's you know it's
often called centrifugal force and
people make a big fuss about the fact
that there isn't really a centrifugal
force it's just the centripetal force of
you pulling the weight to prevent it
from escaping but but for all practical
purposes there is the analog of a force
that is pulling that weight out as you
twirl it around okay so the idea of
these guys is to twelve things around
fast enough that if you just let the
thing escape at just the right moment
it'll be going faster
it'll be--it'll have enough outward
force that you can launch it into orbit
and it's kind of remarkable that
something like that could work I mean
that you could have something twirling
around and you'd make you go faster
faster faster and then at just the right
moment you open this little door and you
let the thing come out and go into orbit
so they claim there I saw these guys so
six months ago or something they claimed
they were not far away from from doing
real tests of this but that's sort of an
idea for how to how to make something go
into orbit by just basically throwing it
into orbit I mean usually a rocket the
rocket itself is pushing you know the
thing to go faster and faster and faster
this the idea is you have this giant
sort of gun and you're basically
shooting things into orbit now a
question which was asked here by Brian
was what about a railgun in space that
launches Rockets interesting so okay
couple of points so first of all if you
have a thing that is where which is
launching a rocket in one direction that
that's really a non-starter because you
really have to have okay when you when
you launch a rocket from the let's say
you have a railgun and it's shooting a
satellite into orbit from the earth
there will be a slight recoil to the
earth in other words when that satellite
is pushed when the all this momentum
goes to push that satellite out into
orbit it's going at 17,000 miles an hour
it's going to go into orbit it's a
satellite it weighs you know I don't
know half a ton let's say you've got
this all this momentum in the satellite
that was produced by this railgun
because of the conservation of momentum
or otherwise the Newton's third law you
can say it different ways equal every
action has an equal and opposite
reaction
say it in a bunch of different ways but
the basic result is that it's a fact of
physics which actually I can now explain
from much more fundamental origins why
that fact is true but Tim many case it's
a true fact that you if you have if you
kind of create momentum you push
something out in one direction you'll
get a recoil in the other direction okay
here's how the math works so momentum is
for these purposes its mass times
velocity
so momentum something is the mass of the
thing times its velocity and so when you
say you're conserving momentum you've
got these two things and it has to be
the case that the momentum going one
direction has to be the same as the
momentum going another direction if you
have this rocket that let's say a
satellite that weighs a ton and it's
going at 17,000 miles an hour which is
orbital speed for the earth then that
will be a certain momentum so we could
work out let me just work this out just
place here let's do the calculation so
what we're going to do is we're going to
say let's say 17,000 miles per hour
times one ton and then we're going to
say divided by mass of Earth okay so
what we're going to do here is that
we'll work out we're going to say the
rocket going in one direction and oh my
gosh
that's amusing um okay so the the rocket
is going one direction it weighs a ton
it's going at 17,000 miles an hour it's
being launched from the earth the earth
will recoil as a result of that launch
how much will the earth recoil
well the momentum is the mass times the
velocity so that means the mass times
the velocity for the satellite is one
time times 17,000 miles an hour the
momentum for the earth is the mass of
the Earth times whatever velocity it
recoils with so we can you know take the
equation we can work that out
so I just computed escape velocity of
Earth times 1 ton divided by mass of the
earth okay so that's telling me what the
recoil speed of the earth is from that
from shooting the satellite out from the
railgun the answer is well I'll say it
in science notation 2.5 times 10 to the
minus 18 miles per hour so that means it
is a million trillionth of a mile per
hour so in other words the earth because
the earth is so heavy
the recoil from the on the earth
associated with launching that one-ton
satellite of that high speed is
absolutely tiny never notice that it's a
million trillionth of a mile per hour
that the earth would recoil as a result
of launching that satellite okay the
problem is if you put a railgun in space
you don't have all of them
you know unless you put that railgun on
a great big asteroid or something um
that male railgun if it's just floating
in space and it launches the satellite
out at some you know let's say it
launches it at a hundred thousand miles
an hour then the railgun depending on
how much heavier the railgun is than the
satellite the railgun will recoil with a
comparable speed and and the actually
what why was that caused a problem that
um um let's see no you can still get I
I'm I'm I'm getting this wrong you can
by having the recoil is not that
important because you can still have
it's like an explosion and in space the
fact that the total momentum of the
explosion is zero doesn't mean that you
can't have things going in the two
directions really fast so okay so I'm
taking this back and I'm saying um if
you could get so I'm ignore my recoil
stuff the the fact is if you just had
this railgun in space and it was
launching something in one direction the
rip the railgun would recoil in the
other direction yeah it wouldn't stay in
one place but you might nevertheless be
able to launch something out in that
direction okay what will be a problem
with this well one problem is how do you
power the railgun where does it get its
energy from you know it's got to be
storing um so one thing you could do is
you could have the railgun have a a
giant solar cell so it's collecting
energy from from the Sun for example
storing it up and then storing it in
some big capacitor that stores
electricity and um and then boom it
launches the thing out from the railgun
so actually that's not a terrible idea
that's that some might work I don't know
you know you have to figure out how much
energy you can store how much
electricity you could store in a battery
or a capacitor that you've collected
from the Sun and then what you would do
is probably you would collect the the
energy from from from you know turn it
from from light into electricity I
collect it for a month let's say and
then say okay we're gonna use all of the
stuff all the energy we collected we're
going to use it to power this railgun to
shoot this thing out really fast so it's
an interesting idea I I have not heard
that idea as I as a kind of
a concept for how to make come maybe
there's some problem with it but I it's
um seems like a good idea yeah um okay
let's see
[Music]
suggestions on the lifestream about
about how to power spacecraft another
one is micro nuclear explosions from
Lewis um yes that was one that was
thought about in the early 1960s
actually is to have is to use because
nuclear power released says a lot more
energy when you have a chemical reaction
like you are burning hydrogen and oxygen
that releases a certain amount of energy
but that's only energy associated with
the reforming of chemical bonds and that
energy is is very small compared to the
energy associated with nuclear bonds
with breaking up nuclei and things like
that so you can and that's why nuclear
reactors nuclear explosions can be quite
powerful so yes that is actually
something that was thought about early
1960s basically what happened is there
was an idea to have a spacecraft that
will be powered by tiny nuclear
explosions the the big downer of having
nuclear explosions in space is nuclear
explosions produce these electromagnetic
pulses which essentially destroy
satellites because they basically induce
voltages in the electronics and
satellites that will fry that that's
that electronics unless it's very well
protected that's one problem the other
problem was that the world decided to
have a nuclear test-ban so that that
term said initially you couldn't new
tests in the atmosphere and later on you
couldn't do tests even on the ground of
nuclear weapons and most countries in
the world with the exception of
countries like North Korea follow that
that treaty that says that you can't you
can't detonate nuclear explosions but in
particular sort of an early thing was
you can't detonate nuclear explosions in
the atmosphere or in space so that was
kind of the that was that was why people
abandoned that idea for for doing it but
but actually that's a I don't know how
how successfully there was a thing
called Project Orion that was an effort
to to imagine a a nuclear-powered
spacecraft I actually don't know the
details of what's involved in that I
think you know one of the issues is you
know nuclear
are pretty violent and you know in a in
a you have to have sort of it's no good
if you're if the nuclear explosion
destroys your spacecraft as well as you
know making a space golf go faster and I
don't I don't know how you avoid that
I'm sure that was that was thought about
um and I you know the problem is a
nuclear explosion is because of this
notion of critical mass that is what
leads to the possibility of nuclear
explosions I don't think maybe I'm wrong
but I don't think that you can have a
let's think I I I don't think you can
have a really tiny nuclear explosion I
think it has to be it has to have a
certain minimum size um and oh gosh
there's lots and lots of questions here
um
let's see um ah gosh there was a recent
question here from Fraxel is a possible
wilmut no from Anders does the Sun emit
electromagnetic pulses and if so how are
satellites protected yes the Sun there
are solar flares and solar flares
well solar flares the main problem with
solar flares is that the from the Sun
you know most of what the Sun produces
is light but the Sun also produces a
stream of electrons and other kinds of
particles and protons actually that
stream towards the earth and an out from
the Sun and they make the at least the
lower energy part of cosmic rays and the
earth is protected from from most of
those things by its magnetosphere that's
kind of a magnetic sheath around the
earth that Tim that makes those
particles that deflects those particles
but Tim when you get them when when
there's a violent enough solar flare you
have a big burst of of those of those
particles and that can in fact damage
satellites now there's a you can look up
in fact we have it in morph now for the
space weather forecast so let's see what
the space weather is today space weather
is all about the amount of the amount
that's coming from the Sun so let's see
gosh I don't really know how to read
this
um the okay the the planetary KP index
is two four hours ago and it seems like
it has been bouncing up and down between
zero and two recently but I think let's
see the the density of the solar wind is
three point four particles per cubic
centimeter right now so that means that
the particles streaming out from the Sun
if we were to look that's a very small
number of particles so in every in every
cubic centimetre okay there are three
point four particles that are coming
from the Sun and in space and the
effective temperature is sixty thousand
degrees centigrade apparently and
usually the the and that there are these
there these flares where that density
will become much larger
now the other thing that happens is that
the the amount of of that activity is
also related to sunspots so on the
surface of the Sun they're essentially
these giant magnetic storms on the
surface of the Sun that are sunspots and
if you look at the so the number of
sunspots varies in there's a roughly
11-year I think its 11-year cycle in
sunspot activity which I don't think
anybody understands so for example right
now I'm looking at this sum this result
right now there are no sunspots visible
on the surface of the Sun but like come
in 2000 I'm looking at this plot there
were a hundred and fifty sunspots
visible on the surface of the Sun and so
it goes up and down and up and down and
up and down there's a very strange thing
back in the 1650s there was this long
period of time between 1650 and 1700
there was this long period of time when
there were very few sunspots visible and
that also coincided with a time when the
temperature of the surface of the earth
was colder and nobody really understands
that it's called the maunder minimum
nobody really understands that
phenomenon and the the the fact it's
possible that the amount of heat output
by the Sun is actually related to these
things like sunspot densities but that's
a so what what can happen with
satellites is there are there are solar
flare as they happen from time to time
there was one that happened oh gosh when
was it it was some who when was that
about 25 years ago maybe um there was a
solar flare that knocked out some
satellites
um and caused caused various kinds of
problems and I don't know I think I
think nowadays that satellites tend to
try to be protected from those kinds of
things but anyway you can look at
there's a you know there's a space
weather which tells you you know how
much you know what what's happening with
the solar wind which is just this wind
of particles electrons and protons not a
wind like on the earth where it's air
and so on it's a wind of particles
coming from the Sun and that that can
happen there um
okay oh there's a question here about
light is made of light how can light go
around and a thing okay so so what
happens is if you have a laser beam for
example that laser beam you can think of
it as being made from huge numbers of
photons huge numbers of little particles
of light and those particles of light
are it's a strange thing but it's just
like just like you have just like you
drop something on earth the gravity of
the earth will pull the thing down the
same thing happens for photons there's a
tiny effect of the photons if you if you
let that beam of light I mean the speed
of light is so fast compared to the
escape velocity of the earth that you
know you shoot your laser into space and
the photons will just go off into space
the only thing that doesn't have that
property is a black hole where its
gravity is so so strong that it will
pull back even those photons from light
so what what can happen is that gravity
can have an effect on these photons now
most things don't have an effect on
photons for example if you have a
magnetic field photons they don't care
they just go straight through actually
there is a small effect the polarization
of photons which has to do with the kind
of well is is affected by magnetic
fields but they're not a photon you've
got a magnetic field says I don't care
the photon just goes straight through a
gravitational field there will be a
small pull from gravity on the photon
that tongue will make it will make it
change its direction and you know on on
earth we don't get to see that actually
there is a phenomenon called the
gravitational redshift which has been
observed on the earth with photons where
when you try and have a photon
the-the-the the energy of a photon which
turns into its it's frequency and it's
and its color effectively as light if
you as a famous experiment where we're
having photons try to try to sort of
going going against the Earth's gravity
they will get slightly less energy they
don't go because of the way photons work
because photons are massless their speed
is always the speed of light but the
energy of a photon can be slightly less
as a result of being sort of pull
back by gravity and similarly the
momentum of a photon which is which
determines the direction it goes in can
be distorted by the pull of gravity and
that's why photon can be turned um okay
so many questions um okay
a question from I'm looking at the end
here from Catalan can you build a
satellite with off-the-shelf electronics
such as a Raspberry Pi buy that will
succeed in space by providing some basic
shielding okay so there is a these days
lots of people fly little satellites
they're things called CubeSat switch a
little little tiny sort of cubes and you
can pay I forget what it is I think
maybe ten thousand dollars or something
is enough to fly a small amount of
electronics into Earth orbit and that
price will only come down and so yes you
can you can get a small satellite you
can just make it with a radio antenna
you can put a Raspberry Pi on it that's
actually a thing I think it's called a
strop I which is a project to have a
sort of a space ready version of the
Raspberry Pi computer these are like 30
$50 little tiny computers and yes people
do that I mean unfortunately it's a it's
a tough business because you know your
satellite gets taken up by a big rocket
you know a SpaceX rocket or something
like that it's in a big rack with lots
of a little cube SATs the rocket gets
into orbit and then it's like okay let's
go all these cube SATs out into orbit so
they go out and orbit and then the first
question is can you find your CubeSat in
other words you're detecting it from the
earth it goes around the earth every 90
minutes and it's like oh can we detect
it actually I have a friend who's who's
who flew one of these cube SATs and they
lost their CubeSat
so the thing was was released from a
rocket and they never managed to get
radio communication with it and you know
it can be tricky because if the thing is
tumbling in space its radio antenna may
not be pointing the direction you think
it's pointing in you may not know
there's in all the objects in orbit
around the earth are being tracked by
radar so if you have a metal object even
a bolt that fell off some spacecraft it
produces because it's metal
radar which is radio waves will be well
will kind of bounce off the the metal
boat
much more intensely than they'll bounce
off otherwise I'll just go off into
space but the radar radar is you send
out a radio pulse and if it and you see
whether something comes back and so if
there's a boat there will come back and
so NORAD North American air defense
operation tracks basically everything in
orbit and so for example we get a feed
from from NORAD that comes into our
Wolfen alpha system that gives the
basically position of every object
that's in orbit around the earth down to
the boats and actually your musk SpaceX
company just launched this some StarLink
collection of satellites and that's what
300 satellites or something that were
launched in the from this big rack and
those are those are just they're all
tracked you can you can go find where
all of them are actually what what
actually happens is what NORAD provides
us is is not the instantaneous position
of every satellite they provide a thing
called the tle data which is it's called
two line elements and what those give is
they say basically what the parameters
of the orbit are so they say you know is
this thing orbiting around the equator
is it orbiting around the pole how fast
is it orbiting our high is it orbiting
turns out you need to give a certain
number of mathematical parameters to
determine the orbit and then we just
compute based on those those parameters
we compute where the satellite will be
at a particular moment when you ask the
question but yeah so the answer is you
you can you know you you can make a
basic satellite now I think as you try
to get beyond low-earth orbit I think
you're subject to much more radiation
and I think it becomes significantly
more difficult what was typically done
so so satellites so electronics that
gets flown and satellites particularly
they're going you know into deep space
and so on you you end up having to have
microprocessors that are arranged so
that they're not so subject to to being
destroyed by a radioactive particle
by cosmic rays and things going through
them a common trick is to have multiple
CPUs and to say oh you know we have
three CPUs and whatever decision we're
going to make about whether the
spacecraft fires its thrusters or
whether it should return a message to
earth let's by majority vote say if two
of the CPUs say do it then we do it
because gosh they you know some cosmic
ray might have gone through one of the
CPUs and caused it to produce a goofy
answer at that moment so that's a that's
a kind of common technique and mostly
these radiation going through well
eventually it will destroy our
electronics but but at the beginning all
it's doing is to make the electronics
sort of do the wrong computation come
out with the wrong result but that's I
mean usually in the okay I don't know
the current story with this but but
usually there are when you buy a semi
Croesus hammock you know semiconductor
device there are usually I'm pretty out
of date with this so don't don't you go
look it up if you want to find out the
latest but used to be the case that you
buy a piece of electronics and you would
buy some chip and it would have
designation no.74 or something or other
um and that first digit was a sort of
characterization of what kind of a chip
was it was it an ordinary
commercial-grade chip or was it a
military-grade chip um
and the military-grade chips I think
they had a v designation back in the day
I don't know what's the case now those
military-grade chips were made to
withstand for example more
electromagnetic you know some degree of
sort of electromagnetic pulse and
radiation and all these kinds of things
I mean that was particularly something
of relevance during the Cold War and so
on but um in any case so that those are
on and typically you don't get the very
latest fanciest fastest CPUs and not
available in these kind of radiation
hardened forms but I think that's on
these space probes I think that's what
you still have to use I don't think
there's been a way around that you can
also put shielding around these things
but shielding is heavy
I mean shielding if you if you put for
example lead letters is sort of because
it's the the heaviest stable element it
has some it does the best at stopping
charged particles like protons from the
Sun or something getting through things
but
but it has its you need quite a you know
for example we could look it up here for
the charged particles from the Sun that
are that are the most popular today
let's see ion temperatures 60,000
kelvins so we could work out what the
energy of those is and we can work out
what how much thickness of lead you need
to be able to shield from that I don't
know what the answer will be but I think
it will be it might be something quite
thick which means it will be quite heavy
to use as shielding um yeah there's a
question from Jamie here what additional
shielding technologies do you think will
be best to use for space radiation when
astronauts head toward Mars I mean
people have talked about putting big
water tanks you know it's like if you're
going to store water for the trip to
Mars although you typically will have to
recycle all of it but you know store
that on the exterior of the spacecraft
to use that as a as a piece of shielding
I don't know I don't know exactly what
the what what the physics of that is all
right let's take a look come let's go
back here and and okay there are a bunch
of questions here about can you find an
element that would make an
indestructible spacesuit it's a question
about um what are the unique properties
of element 115 so let's talk a little
bit about that okay so people may
probably know about the periodic table
actually a good friend of mine and
person who worked at my company for 25
years named Te'o gray has made this very
lovely periodic table that is up in a
very large fraction of school chemistry
labs it's a it's a it's a periodic table
in which has a picture of a sample of
pretty much every elements in the
periodic table so people know periodic
table starts you know hydrogen helium
lithium beryllium boron carbon nitrogen
oxygen fluorine neon sodium magnesium
that right I don't know I I have to I
have to look it up I'm sorry I don't
know my um one of my kids memorized
pretty much the whole thing but I'm
afraid I'm I'm
I'm not some I'm not that good um
but any case the the periodic table
lists all these different chemical
elements what are these chemical
elements these chemical elements are
distinguished by what is in the nucleus
of the atoms that correspond to those
elements so hydrogen is element number
one it has one proton in its nucleus
helium is element number two it has two
protons in its nucleus beryllium element
helium lithium lithium is number three
has three protons in its nucleus and so
on and so each different kind of element
is distinguished by the number of
protons it has in its nucleus um and
there are also in addition to protons in
the nucleus of the atom there also
neutrons and there are different
isotopes that correspond to having
different numbers of neutrons so for
example for hydrogen the most common
form of hydrogen is what's often called
protium which is hydrogen which has one
just a proton as its nucleus but there's
also a thing called deuterium which is
hydrogen that has a proton and a neutron
as its nucleus and so for example water
h2o you can have d2o which is deuterium
oxide where instead of having ordinary
ordinary hydrogen and an oxygen you have
hydrogen where the nucleus we have this
different isotope of hydrogen where the
hydrogen is some is made from a proton
and a neutron and so that makes what's
called heavy water which is important in
nuclear reactors because heavy water
absorbs many more neutrons which is an
important issue in nuclear reactors than
ordinary water absorbs so heavy water is
a is an important thing to have if
you're making nuclear reactors now heavy
water occurs oh boy I think I think it's
one in 10,000 hydrogen atoms is has an
extra is that right has an extra has
that extra Neutron so it's a the so in
in naturally natural abundance of let's
see what it is I not tell you the wrong
thing the natural abundance of deuterium
is
um oh I was right one point five ten to
the minus four so about one in ten
thousand atoms of hydrogen has that
different nucleus with an extra Neutron
in it um and so that's but by the way
hydrogen has another isotope that's
called tritium which is one one proton
and two neutrons in the nucleus of the
hydrogen atom that makes tritium and
tritium has okay so here's a funny story
so tritium has pretty low abundance on
the earth because it's only made it is
unstable I just looked it up the the
half-life of tritium is twelve years so
in twelve years half if you have a bunch
of tritium in twelve years half of it
will have decayed away so it will decay
the the nucleus will will basically fall
apart and will turn into a nucleus of
ordinary hydrogen plus some particles
will fly off probably um I think what is
the decay mode it is a beta emission
decay so okay so it term yeah I thought
it'll decay to here it'll actually turn
into helium plus an electron one of the
neutrons will turn into a proton
emitting by emitting an electron so that
happens so if you have a bottle of
tritium every every 12 years or so
there'll only be half of it left and you
wait another 12 years half of that will
be left and it will decay exponentially
with time okay so how much tritium is
there on the earth well tritium is made
by those cosmic rays by things by by for
example high-energy particles from the
Sun will make a small amount of tritium
when they interact with water on the
earth but actually when I was a kid the
you know I remember I forget the actual
number but you know the certain amount
of tritium one one part in a trillion
let's say of water on the earth had the
hydrogen in it was tritium okay and if
you look
up that number now the number would much
smaller so the question is what an earth
changed on the earth so to speak between
when I was a kid let's say 50 years ago
and and now and the answer is that
nuclear explosions nuclear tests in the
atmosphere of the earth produced enough
radioactivity that tritium they produce
tritium that ended up in the oceans of
the earth and the oceans mix enough that
your average little piece of water that
you just get from somewhere had tritium
that was created by those nuclear
explosions in it and that term and so
but that tritium that existed when I was
a kid has decayed by now and so there's
less tritium around so if you look in a
chemistry book or something and you say
and says what's the abundance of tritium
you look at a book from the 1960s it'll
give a different value in the book today
because the tritium that existed that
was produced in the in the Earth's
oceans by those nuclear tests has
decayed away it was actually pretty
interesting for people to figure out
mixing of ocean water by by tracing that
tritium on things I'm independent of the
category of bad ideas of testing nuclear
weapons in the Earth's atmosphere and
things but that's a that's a different
story um it's what you've never tested
you don't know what's going to happen
and it's in any case but any case so
it's so back to back to this idea of
chemical elements so so it turns out
most chemical elements are stable in the
sense that you know you have some gold
which is element number 79 I think you
have some tungsten my favorite element
because it's its other name is Wolfram
it's has symbol W that's element number
74 that means it has 74 protons in its
nucleus
most of these elements are stable they
last for the whole history of the
universe you'd have a piece of tungsten
it'll stick around for as long as
nothing will go wrong with its nucleus
its nucleus will not decay but other
elements decay and by the time you get
to uranium element well the time we get
beyond uranium our uranium is on
90 to 92 protons in its nucleus by the
time you get beyond uranium all
subsequent elements are unstable they
decay typically their nuclei one of the
things that can happen well they're
bunch of different ways that nuclei can
decay usually alpha beta gamma emission
and nuclear fission um the different
nuclei decay in different ways okay so
one of the confusing things is that you
might say well that means when the
nucleus gets too big it'll just fall
apart
and so everything bigger than 92 protons
just fall apart but anything smaller
than 92 protons it will be just fine
turns out that's not correct they're
actually a two elements technetium and
promethium that are not so not so many
protons technetium has 43 protons in its
nucleus
promethium has 960 protons in its
nucleus if you look in the periodic
table those two elements are not stable
so my friend Thao Gray's periodic table
posters his technetium well I don't know
what he'll have it for the picture for
technetium but technetium decays and so
does so does promethium you know the
origin of tayos and periodic table
picture was at some point Thao was very
instrumental in building the user
interface for for these things called
war from notebooks back in the day and
at some point he kind of finished a lot
of that work and he was a little bit
bored and so he sort of developed a
hobby and the hobby he developed was he
decided to make a periodic table table
so the notion was to have an actual
wooden table where underneath each tool
you know it has a bunch of little boxes
in it and underneath each each little
little box in the table is the element
that corresponds to that position in the
periodic table so he has some it's
actually at our company it's the
original periodic table table exists
there with with samples of all these
elements but when we get to Elements 43
it's missing because that's a
radioactive element and and it wouldn't
well I don't know how long that what the
lifetime of technetium is but we don't
really want radioactive elements sitting
around in a in a table in in the middle
of our company
but in case so so there are these weird
anomalous elements that are unstable and
probably the reason for that is when you
make an atomic nucleus you've got these
protons and neutrons and they're all
little balls basically and the question
is when you have a certain number of
balls and you try and stick them
together if you have a certain number of
balls you'll you'll end up that you can
make a very densely packed lump of these
balls but then maybe one of them is has
to stick out just because of the the
structure of you know if you have a
bunch of spheres and you try and pack
them together certain numbers of spheres
pack really well and other numbers of
Spears don't pack so well and that may
have something to do with why there are
some weird elements that are unstable
just because with that number of protons
and neutrons there isn't a way to pack
them quite as well it's not very well
understood but to notice when you get to
really heavy elements um the and a first
approximation beyond 92 they're all
unstable okay when I was a kid people
often used to talk about this thing they
called the island of stability people
said maybe when we reach elements 115 or
120 maybe we will get elements that are
stable again they have various arguments
for this turns out didn't happen that
way um now I forget what the largest
maybe 116 or something as they is the
heaviest element that's been produced
these elements usually are very unstable
and decay extremely quickly but there's
nothing to absolutely be sure that there
isn't going to be an element 130 or
something that if you ever once made it
it will be stable now the only reason we
think that isn't the case is because we
think that explosions of stars like
supernovas if it was possible to make
those elements would have made them
because in those very violent explosions
you're kind of producing you're having
lots of nuclear reactions that will
produce lots of kinds of elements and
you would think of it was possible to
make that that kind of element and that
it would have been made there I mean
like for example all the gold that
exists on the earth was pretty much made
in in supernovas at least it was made in
stars there are actually two ways it can
be made but but some part of it was made
in supernova explosions of old stars
that died long before the Sun was
created and that's sort of how heavier
elements get made and you might think if
there were heavier elements that they
would have been made in supernova
explosions but maybe there's a reason
they're not
and maybe one day somebody will be able
to you know these so-called heavy ion
accelerators where you basically take
two atomic nuclei and you smash them
together at incredibly high speed and
some of the time they kind of stick and
make a heavier nucleus um and maybe
somebody will do that one day and now
make element 140 or something that will
turn out to be stable and have all kinds
of weird properties we don't know there
is something that happens elements above
137 do very very weird things I love
it's a hub of 137 okay in so in a
typical atom you have the nucleus and
you have electrons that are kind of in
this cloud around the nucleus and the as
the nucleus the charge of the nucleus
attracts electrons to it there that
because their electron charge is
opposite to the charge and proton in the
nucleus there's a force of electrical
attraction between the the the electrons
and the protons and that force of
attraction if the if the charge on the
nucleus if they're more than 137 protons
in the nucleus that force of attraction
is so strong that it actually is strong
enough that it's it's there's more
energy associated with that attraction
than the rest mass of an electron and so
what that means is you have a bizarre
phenomenon called auto-ionization where
essentially what happens is that it is
energetically favorable to create
electron positron pairs electron
anti-electron
we make anti electrons and electrons and
you spontaneously produce those around
this nucleus and that what will actually
happen presumably is the nucleus will
quickly get shielded by this sort of
cloud of positrons and electrons and so
on around it but it's a really weird
phenomenon where where you're kind of
spontaneously producing particles as a
result of the the the features of the
nucleus or at least that's what's
thought to happen I mean if the people
who are interested in me at the okay
I'll say the technical thing the the
lowest energy when you solve the Dirac
equation for the Coulomb potential for a
nucleus with Z greater than 100
seven the the lowest energy state lowest
energy eigenstate for the Dirac equation
goes gets to have less than zero energy
and that's what that's what produces
this sum this weird effect that was
probably sorry that was that was just
techno speak for it's sort of
interesting to hear what the techno
speak for these things is but anyways so
the answer is we don't know you know
it's very hard to compute the properties
of like element 115 it's it decays very
that particular one decays very quickly
but if we could produce if it turns out
that there's a heavier elements a
particular isotope over however elements
that is stable um you know we might be
able to maybe we can produce it somehow
and we if you ask what kind of chemical
properties might it have the answer is
we really don't know very well it's it's
a hard thing to work out in the periodic
table one of the ideas of Mendeleev in
the original construction of the
periodic table is that the you're
arranging the elements in such a way
that the so called periods the sort of
that the elements that are arranged on
top of each other in the periodic table
have somehow similar properties so for
example the noble gases over on the
right-hand side that go helium neon
ah
xenon Krypton francium I think those are
those are all gases that are that react
only very very little and they're all
the ones that are in the and the in the
right-hand side of the periodic table
and the reason it works that way is when
these electrons are that there are those
are the the things that have so-called
filled shells of electrons they have all
of their electrons are paired up in a
certain way and that makes these these
atoms much less likely to try and react
with other atoms and that's what leads
these those particular elements to have
them and those are sort of we know that
sort of roughly in the periodic table
when we have a filled shell of electrons
then we'll tend to have a less
chemically reactive substance so we can
make some statements like that but doing
the exact computation is quite hard
um and it's some I think it's becoming
closer I mean I think we have actually
you can use modern machine learning
methods to make oh I don't know I'm
basis functions for the Schrodinger for
these wave functions to do a little bit
better anyway okay let's look at a
couple of other questions and we're kind
of running into these these are such fun
I'm sorry I'm um there's a question here
from Alonzo will music again have a
place in science as it had in ancient in
ancient Greece an interesting question
so
you know music has has certain
regularities to it
that for example when we think about a
musical scale you know we or the we play
different musical notes that we know now
from physics of it that each musical
note has a certain frequency it
corresponds to sound waves which are
where your way of vibrating the air at a
certain frequency when you go up an
octave you are doubling the frequency of
those vibrations so for example middle C
is about 256 vibrations per second 256
Hertz and the the next C up one octave
up is twice that that frequency so so we
know that and it turns out that our when
we perceive sound in our ears
those that factor of two we kind of
perceive those notes as being very
similar it's at C and it's another C and
the reason for that has to do with the
actual way that vibrations work inside
our inner ears where the sound is is
being detected by little tiny hair cells
on the surface of our inside our cochlea
and those hair cells are wiggling and
they have an electrical effect they have
essentially a as you as you move the
hair cell it's it's it's kind of like a
like a nerve cell that it's like like
like touch is as a result of nerve cells
that are responsible that produce a
chemical electrochemical effect when you
touch them so similarly the hair cells
in the air when you when they get
wiggled by the sound going into your ear
they produce a electrical effect that
goes through your auditory nerve to your
to your brain and that's how you
perceive that the sound but so the way
that works physically is such that when
you double the frequency it actually
doesn't we perceive that as being sort
of a similar kind of note so there are
other things that we know about music
like for example a major v is a
frequency ratio of three-halves
one and a half times so it's c2g is a
frequency change of one and a half times
at least depending on exactly how you
tune your piano or your violin or
whatever um but but roughly that's a you
know that so they're these numbers these
frequency ratios and by the way those
frequency ratios when you have a
stringed instrument those frequency
ratios also turn out to be related to
the lengths of the strings that you when
you pluck them they produce sounds of
those of those frequencies so so it
turns out that our perception of sound
is we really notice these these sort of
numerical ratios in sounds and so that
was you know the pythagorean's back in
the fifth century BC were you know they
were they were very big on these kind of
the fact that these these different
ratios of lengths of strings would
produce you know these numerical ratios
of a string that's three-halves the
length of some other string will produce
a sound that harmoniously goes with that
other sound that was a that was sort of
a big thing and so that that was an
early kind of place where mathematics
seemed to be relevant to something that
we humans were dealing with but
pythagorean's also believed in some
other things that to us would seem
completely wacky about the way that
mathematics was relevant to sort of
human affairs and they had this whole
scheme of the called the tractus which
was this whole scheme about oh i
forgotten it there was some oh I don't
remember it was it was a thing where
where these different numbers would
represent different genders and
different lists than that and the others
it was it was a pretty wacky scheme to
us today but that their scheme for music
was you know that works and and it's
it's a way of sort of relating numerical
things to to musical things now when it
comes to so that that's sort of the the
frequencies of musical notes and we
understand a certain amount now about
why from the physics of ears and things
about why certain ratios of frequencies
are pleasing for example there are
things called try tones which are a
frequency ratio of square root of 2
which is not a rational number it's not
like
Hobbs or 3/4 or something like that it's
a number which you can't write as a
ratio of two whole numbers that
frequency ratio is one that is
particularly displeasing to us
particularly unpleasing does if you play
a a tritone chord um it'll be like oh
that's a terrible sound and I actually
have a theory about why that is but but
um to do it the way that it makes some
sort of fun
well things called beat notes which are
which are things we got from
combinations of sounds in our ears and
on our auditory nerve that that's that I
have a sort of theory about why why we
don't like hearing those sounds because
it kind of confuses the signals on our
auditory nerve but no case so they're
facts like that so that's in the
structure of actual sort of structure of
music and you know in the early days
music was much better developed than for
example in mathematics you know when
Kepler in the in the early 1600s was
talking about you know that the trying
to describe the planets and so on he
would talk about the music of the
spheres and actually if you look at his
book he had he used musical notation
which was developed around a thousand ad
musical notation of you know writing
notes on a stave and things that was
developed around I think thousand 1068
ad or something a monk called something
a reso
that there been precursors of it but the
notation that we have today was
developed around that time so a thousand
ad was developed much earlier than
mathematical notation was developed
mathematical notation wasn't developed
until mail really until 1600s was was
when it really took off and so when
Kepler was doing this stuff in the early
1600s his notation some of his notation
was based on on musica music notation he
actually has these these musical pieces
as part of his description of the
planets and so on so so but then
mathematical notation took off and that
was a much richer way to represent
things now when it comes to musical
pieces that's the individual notes when
it comes to a whole musical piece that's
sort of the whole structure of the piece
has a certain as a certain character to
it has certain logic to it and there
there are things you know when you have
a few bees and so on they have certain
structure and you can have sort of
sequences where there's a piece you know
a piece of music looks like a piece of
music looks like a piece of music with
like B then it sort of repeats with
another a and a B and a B and an A and
so on and you have this sort of
structural repetitions and so on so it's
interesting to see to what extent those
kind of structural almost computational
things are what leads to music being
pleasing being boring being whatever
actually we had a project back in the
around 2007 thing we call Wolfram tones
which you can go find on the web which
uses essentially computational very
simple programs very simple computer
programs that would sort of randomly
picked and these little programs go and
make pieces of music and the way that
site works is we try a whole bunch of
programs you might try a thousand old
programs and then we find one where we
say this program kind of reminds us of I
don't know some jazz music or something
so that's what we produce if you press
the button that says make a piece of
jazz music and it's made sort of at
random by by sampling this computational
universe of possible programs but each
of these programs has a certain logic
about how it works and when we hear it
we can kind of detect the fact that oh
these are not random notes these are
notes that have some kind of logic that
determines how they were made so that's
a kind of an interesting interesting
angle there I mean there are there a
bunch of different sort of commonalities
between music and mathematics that that
get explored I think that the in modern
machine learning we can kind of learn a
bunch about the typical forms that
humans find pleasing and we can
potentially knit those together to make
sort of pleasing pieces of music I don't
think that's been super successful yet
but it's getting there there are all
kinds of questions you can ask that the
different musical scales major scales
minor scales
you know pentatonic scales where you're
playing all the more than you know
including the black notes and so on um
the UM
the things that there are actually let's
see there are twelve semitones and an
octave so there are two to the eleven
possible that's
2,048 possible musical scales by picking
different notes although some of the
scales are pretty uninteresting because
they involve playing no notes and so a
question you can ask is if you look
around the world at different forms of
music what different scales have people
used and the answer is that about 400
kinds of scales that have been used in
different you know styles of music from
you know Indonesian - you know - I don't
know different different different
traditions musical traditions have used
different scales and about 400 of the
2048 possibilities have been have been
used historically so that's it's sort of
a type of mathematical thing you can ask
about music another thing you can start
asking is we have these musical
instruments that produce certain
patterns of vibration and we certainly
don't know that the patterns of
vibration we know so far from different
musical instruments are the only ones
that might seem pleasing to us and
that's another kind of area of
exploration it sort of mathematics and
music um alright maybe one more this is
I'm having such fun I'm sorry
the
[Music]
boy we got a lot of good questions here
I I'm gonna have to do this again next
week a lot of interesting questions as
questions about theology here can talk
about that that's interesting um
you
okay there's a there's a kind of
question here um from senko moon how do
I win the fight against fear of learning
something if it looks really
intimidating you know I spent my life
learning about different kinds of things
and you know every time I'm learning
about something it always is like oh my
gosh I'm never going to understand this
I'll give you an example actually played
out even today there's an area of
mathematics called category theory which
is one of the most abstract areas of
mathematics and I've been afraid of
category theory for a long time a lot of
mathematicians have been afraid of
category theory because it's so abstract
it's kind of like you're talking about
these things these morphisms these
functors you're talking about these very
very elaborate things and in fact even
more than that there's a thing called
higher-order category theory which it's
even more abstract than whatever okay so
finally I think actually even as of
today I think I really understand higher
order category theory in an interesting
way and I understand how it relates to a
bunch of things I've been thinking about
it how did I get to that point okay so
first of all I read things about
character fading oh my gosh they're so
abstract I can't understand what's going
on it's like consider this kind of you
know can you know these these morphisms
and this and that and the other and it's
it's like I don't know what's going on
okay so how do I get into something like
that well the answer is I I find
something that I kind of understand and
I try to say or a question that I kind
of have really wrapped my brain around I
understand the question now the issue is
can I use these ideas from category
theory to sort of address the question
that I have and you know it may take
picking away in maybe a little corner of
category theory that I use to address
that question
um it's not the whole thing it's like
when I read the first page of the
textbook it's like it does consider this
really weird thing and I'm like I don't
know why I should consider that it seems
really really complicated to me um so
you know what I found is if I've got
some specific question that can be
addressed by this area or that can I can
answer with this area you bite off a
little corner
of the area by just thinking about the
question you're dealing with you don't
have to you don't have to gulp in the
whole giant area you just think about
the thing that you just thought was
interesting and and gradually you'll
understand more and more about the area
and eventually you know you'll you'll be
usually what happens with me I
understand some new area I'll get to the
point I usually have okay so I'll often
talk to people I'll read things and so
on and and what I find is at the
beginning it's like okay I typically use
the strategy I just mentioned of you
know picking a question that I want to
answer using that area to get my kind of
my way into it so to speak
and then I'll start trying to understand
the whole area and I'll get to the point
where every new thing I read I like oh
my gosh I didn't know that every person
I talk to they'll say well did you know
about this so well no I didn't um and so
you know it's very humiliating in a
sense at that point because it's like
every person you talk to everything you
read it's like oh that's something new I
didn't understand that and then for me
with pretty much every area I've ever
looked at there comes this moment when
oh okay I more or less get it and then
every new thing I hear I can fit it into
what I already knew and often I'll say
oh yeah I understand that it fits into
this and listen listen this and this
it's really a cool feeling actually when
you get to that point where you know you
go through this lowest point to me where
I know enough about the area that I can
kind of you know that I'm sort of taking
input about all these different things
and it's like this is really this is
really scary because I'm you know it's
like how many things are there in this
area you know there's I just heard about
and the 20th new thing that I didn't
know about but then suddenly you know
actually sometimes that she's somewhat
sudden usually it all starts to fit
together and it's like okay I get it I
understand all these 20 things they all
make sense they're all different ways to
say some related thing and so on so so
that's that's my approach to those kinds
of things I think that the you know pick
off a question that you want to answer
and that you you know rather than the
central approach of you know read you
know start up by trying to understand
these definitions I found that very
difficult
um I mean another another trick
okay is there are fields where people
you know you get into this field and
it's like well everybody knows all this
complicated stuff and so you know you
look at books about and it's like well
everybody knows these complicated things
it's like well I don't know these
complicated things actually they don't
seem very intuitive to me are they even
correct
I might sometimes wonder what I found is
that textbooks written by people who
were major figures in these fields
usually have introductions that do a
pretty decent job of explaining what the
main point is and that's an often quite
elementary textbook so even if you're
trying to do some quite advanced thing
you know the elementary textbook which
happens to be written by somebody who
really knew that feel really really well
will often start with something which is
actually gives you a better competitive
cognitive map of the field then you'll
find if you you know if you go to
something which is even you know where
you think you're getting a much more
complete story about the field you know
going back to that kind of the
introduction of the elementary textbook
even though the textbook itself may be
utterly incomprehensible the
introduction is is it will be useful
anyway that's a that's a trick I've I've
the let's see
um
[Music]
see well I just I think I publish it
wrap this up it's a question about how
the fear and everything going it's going
great really great I mean it's just
amazing how much stuff were being able
to understand from from existing physics
um
let's see
here from MacGyver gravity effects
photons were photons have no masses it's
a case where energy equals mass yeah
yeah gravity has an effect on photons
actually has two effects there's sort of
an electricity for gravity where you're
just attracting things based on their
essentially their energy and then
there's another effect which is kind of
like gravitational magnetism which is
which affects things that go at a speed
and have they have a momentum as well as
having an energy and actually one of on
Stein's big predictions was that both of
those effects would happen for photons
being deflected by the Sun leading to a
factor of two change in what you might
expect the amount by which a photon will
be bent as it goes around the Sun that
was the thing that was in 1919 verified
supposedly um
[Music]
you
the okay there's
here
[Music]
there's a lot of interests
okay we have this for the next time
asteroid hurling towards the earth what
can we do about it that's an interesting
question
wow this is a question what would I say
is piece of advice for a student
starting the LHCb experiment I am
guessing that that is not a young kid
theme that is an experiment at a giant
particle accelerator in in Switzerland
well actually on the Swiss French border
um and that's a an interesting question
but but for another time
all right um I think we should probably
um it's just a lot of interesting
questions here I'm sorry I wish them
wish we had more time another maybe I
you guys a motivating meter to continue
next week and well I hope they hope you
find this interesting and you're in the
US have a good Memorial Day or else
we're good good weekend and hope to to
be talking to you again next week
Thanks I